so what value is there then to uh denial
any
oh I think they're valued if you really
commit to it
I get this from my mother yeah
so it's a very pragmatic uh value coming
to the denial okay and and and and and
and and and my mom yeah does it to an
extent that that that that I'm like
mom do you have any consideration or
context of situations and she does this
is the thing every time I go she's not a
shallow woman
but if it is not if it is something if
it is something happens
in her life that is
keeping her from going where she wants
to go or having or a joy
in her life that she does
just straight ass deny it happened
didn't happen
no did Mom
we're right here I I heard you yeah what
you said
no didn't you heard something else mom
now
did she get to manage down that she's
91. hell yeah she gets some Amnesty on
that
um but I've
she's not
he had a she repeat offend yeah but it's
it's misdemeanors
you know what I mean I mean it's like we
all it's part of that thing when you got
a family member you're like yep that's
just what they do Just go with it you
know and and and it's and it's
it's ingenious in a way it's a tool she
does I think it is more of a trick with
her she would even so ingrained there
it's not a trick it just do it done
and and I and I another reason I bring
this up it's outside of just my mother
is
I did this uh um
uh
road trip course in this Art of Living
event a few weeks ago
out of
hundreds of thousands of
chats that came in responses that came
in afterwards it seemed to me that about
80 percent of people's challenges
and problems even in their life were
something in the past that they were
hung up on
that they could not seem to get past and
it was it was holding them from going
where they wanted to in their future and
so
I thought that was revealing I would
have thought I would have thought that
was I don't know going in 40 it was
eight it seemed to be 80 yeah
and then I thought about okay
if you're here in the live show and you
want to get the course you're into some
sort of therapy or
education or development or self-help
whatever okay
and I have a lot of
friends and I know a lot of people that
earn weekly and daily
therapy
and then I know there's a lot of people
that are on prescriptions
drugs
and while the therapy
and the right prescription to the right
person for the right
uh diagnosis is is necessary I I'm
questioning
is there a value to going
if you're not getting past this today
this week this month this year almost in
a decade goes by and you're still hung
up and you can't get rid of that thing
and your memory where you
and you've it's got you paralyzed and
you're you're you're a victim of it is
there and you're doing the therapy and
you're doing the work and you're taking
a prescription if that's what you're
taking where does your is there a value
in going
if it's holding you back from going
where you want to go maybe you should
just deny the [__] thing ever [__]
happen Kick It In The Head kick it off
the curb
I'm done with you
I'm sick of you I'm tired of hanging out
with you I'm tired that thing whatever
it is hold me back from going where I
want to go so if I if I can't wax the
car
you know and and and get past this thing
kick it that's so powerful so one thing
to do like with the loss of your father
is to try to transform it to discover
the gift in it the gift and the pain but
if you can't keep looking keep looking
you can't find the gift and the pain
just deny it ever happened
you could call that a trick
but I think it's more than a trick
because let me say this
my mom after my father died went on and
found
a second love of her life
for seven 19 years they were together CJ
Carling
love you buddy he's moved on now
did she check with us a little bit
like is this okay
she gave us a little lingering half a
second look that we knew that maybe was
what she was asking and we came to it
was like yes it's okay and you know who
else is saying it's okay who's dancing
up there for you Dad
so
was that her denying
at the man she was divorced from twice
and married two three times and had
three children with
had moved on no
but she didn't
say I'm not you know
well what's the book on how long I'm
supposed to say single before I can be
interested in another you know there's
not a book on these things
how do you feel is loving is is loving
CJ mean you love Dad less no
is finding a new life and a new dance
partner in this life and CJ mean that
Dad wasn't your dance partner
the dad wasn't the love of your life
no
so I don't know I mean
in there maybe you know maybe there's
another word I think it's denial but
it's not really denial because it's not
like it didn't happen that's a
earlier example I was giving my mom she
will absolutely go
that light's not on Mom the lights on we
just that light's not on if I say it's
not on sometimes you're just like that
makes no sense you just absolutely
denying what just happened we even have
it recorded and she'll go well the
recording's line yeah I mean that's part
of a coping deal with her but I mean
what I think is more important or more
valuable is to talk about this she
didn't deny my dad
dying
I didn't
but she sure as hell Turn the Page
and said I can still start a whole new
category a new life a new love let my
let my heart love and be loved by
someone living
in this life today that I'm still living
in
and that will not trespass on my love
for my husband your father Jim
McConaughey and I think I I mean we were
just
thought that was beautiful yes Mom go
talk about green like go
now if we're hung up going
can't have one or the it can't have them
both
gotta have one or the other now we start
to make a contradiction of the two ideas
again which Dawn our contradictions get
us in trouble all the time man that's
life though the contradictions right
but isn't life if if we just admit the
contradictions or so much don't they
become a paradox if we just admit that
that's part of it yeah if if
contradictions are inevitable they
essentially they do become Paradox don't
they
then were in the Honeywell
then we're sinking and dancing
and have
leniency with ourselves while still
holding our self to task and it's it's
I think it's holding on to know each
contradiction oh here it is again so
it's a one-off it lives on its own
separate from the last one no it doesn't
they're connected that's why they are
Paradox and then that's I think that's a
much
I think that's where life really is
in the Paradox yes and the dance of it